breathe out
brazen
right now
want to see me captain that's right
that's exactly right you want to tell me
what happened with Bo nothing we can't
handle
except he's out for the day with five
stitches on his left eye and I'm
short-staffed for the night shift
don't you [ __ ] smile you have two
options you want to tell me what
happened tell me you slipped his hand
between your legs tried to touch your
[ __ ] you want to make a complaint you
don't want to talk that's an option too
no middle ground
yes sir so what do you want to do now
got off detective you want out
altogether
I can bust you down to the unemployment
office if that's what you want I it's
down on my shift I just want to get a
drink sir get the [ __ ] out of my office
yes sir we got you a P in the house
tonight growling America's favorite anti
transcendentalist
[Music]
yes ma'am ma'am [ __ ] so you can't huh
yeah you can't smoke out of cars what
can't so he can't smoke that in the car
I can't what some driving
come on come on take it take it come on
man take it back
take it back
wait a minute wait a minute hold on hold
on hold on hold on to this person I was
being kidnapped tell it to the judge
where's my joint I don't know hi I
explained so you don't know where my
[ __ ] join us threw it away you threw
a [ __ ] joint away I thought the
police would come huh
so when I got into the cab there's
already 60 dollars and 27 cents on the
meter okay I even noticed it we're like
a mile into the trip okay so you decided
to assault him cabbies in this town of
the worst yeah you know what they don't
think so much are you either [ __ ]
muncher you know how much those
medallions are 80 grand and now and now
thanks to you guys they're worthless cuz
of these get rich quick startup drive
companies I'm gonna call cab back cuz I
didn't want to wait at the station you
know what do you want to get you want to
get smart you want to get smart with me
I called the campus I think uber is evil
I tell you that point yeah the
additional fare the cabby insisted I pay
up right and then he locked the door
[ __ ] believe that that's kidnapping
this shows him in handcuffs excuse me
you she's not have said that
excuse me not enough
drive drive and you drink don't stare
do ya we going back to the police
station I need to key in the new
location
what do you think we should do tough guy
I'm gonna go for a right
nothing what about you what do you think
we should do me yeah you what you don't
think you're responsible for any of this
I don't even know you cowards here I
need the cuffs sit up up I need your
cuffs have a nice night boys go [ __ ]
yourself that was unusual
I get right home
download the app kids bro come on go
little kids home with starving and
famished
who cares bro come on go kids bro come
on go the guild black dudes there's
video evidence
who cares bro look if I go the
government is reading all of your texts
and emails bro in Afghanistan there's no
school for females go go go go go go go